key pieces of president biden's domestic
agenda keep meeting stiff resistance
infighting among congressional democrats
and the white house has not only stalled
the president's trillion-dollar
infrastructure bill it has also forced
revisions on other initiatives the two
sides are battling over how much to cut
the overall price tag of mr biden's
reconciliation package and which social
programs should be funded deborah
alfarone has the latest from the white
house deborah good morning good morning
dana and president biden was on the road
friday and he was touting his 3.5
trillion dollar human infrastructure
spending bill but not everyone is behind
it in fact he acknowledged yesterday
that moderate democrats will they will
probably want it to be cut because they
are struggling to unify behind it
i'm convinced we're going to get it done
we're not going to get 3.5 trillion
dollars
we'll get less than that but we're going
to get it and we're going to come back
and get the rest
speaking at a child care development
center in hartford connecticut the
president said the social safety net
programs in the bill like free community
college free child care and an ambitious
climate change plan are critical for
america to be competitive too many folks
in washington still don't realize it
isn't enough just to invest in our
physical infrastructure
we also have to invest in our people an
obstacle course of compromises lie ahead
to get both his social spending package
and the bipartisan infrastructure bill
passed the battle now sits with moderate
democrats in the house and senate
democrats joe manchin and kirsten cinema
with a 50-50 senate their votes can make
or break biden's agenda i don't believe
that we should turn our society into an
entitlement society this is going to
take time to get this done getting it
done quickly is not going to benefit
anybody
president biden has been negotiating
around the clock with democratic
lawmakers and remains optimistic
negotiation is still going on
there has been progress
but
i'll be
meeting with and talking with folks
today and tomorrow and
on monday
and democratic leaders have a
self-imposed deadline of october 31st
halloween and yesterday president biden
said he was pushing for a quick
resolution but that there was no
specific deadline jeff
we will see deborah thank you